buonasera a tutti mi hanno insegnato il
potere della leggerezza e quindi oggi la
mia storia ve la racconterò così da
bambina il mio più grande cruccio era
quello di non avere una particolare
vocazione
la domanda più fastidiosa che ricevevo
era cosa vuoi fare da grande e allora in
china la testa alzavo il la spalla e
invece di in qualche modo ostentare
sicurezza o stentavo timidezze la
risolvevo così poi a un certo punto però
arrivò il mio primo successo
vi prego di guardare la foto di questo
che io chiamo il mio primo grande grande
trionfo appena afferrata la mia coda di
volpe che vedete nella mano nella mano
destra ad obiettivo raggiunto in qualche
modo l'entusiasmo giovani
e chiaro che dal mio volto la sensazione
di felicità che fino a quel momento
avevo provato e che mio padre avrebbe
catturato se fosse stato solo un po più
veloce non riscattare quella foto era
come dire sbiadita al raggiungimento
dell'obiettivo scesa dal sediolino
pensavo che in qualche modo mi servisse
un altro trionfo un'altra vittoria
un'altra coda di volpe per poi scoprire
nel corso della mia vita che in realtà
la parte più bella era stata il giro in
giostra che dovevo replicare
assolutamente quella sensazione come
molti come molti di voi vedo persone
giovanissime sono arrivata al futuro
ballando al senso di responsabilità
femminile che mi contraddistingue e
cogliendo le opportunità che qualcun
altro aveva strutturato per me gli anni
della scuola sono stati gli anni più
divertenti e anche i sogni di quel
periodo lo sono stato e che altrettanto
vi dico che quando ero bambina ho
davvero pensato e sognato che avrei che
mi sarei meritata un nobel non si sa
esattamente bene per cosa ma vi assicuro
che l'ho sognato e qualora non fossi
riuscita a raggiungere quell'obiettivo
avrei meritato quantomeno un oscar
guardate quest'ultima foto io quel che
in quel periodo non sognavo di sposare
un uomo
come lui io sognavo di sposare proprio
lui
george clooney perché perché in quel
periodo tutto veramente tutto era ancora
possibile
dopo gli stati uniti mi sono laureata in
economia è specializzata in finanza in
una se forse la migliore delle
università economiche italiane per
finire a lavorare dove tutti quelli che
si laureano dove mi sono laureata io
finiscono a lavorare i sogni di
ragazzina anche per fortuna li avete
visti erano ormai svanita svaniti e via
via però le cose diventavano sempre meno
possibili pur avendo vissuto ogni mia
esperienza con grande curiosità goduto
di soddisfazioni devo dire interessante
e soprattutto ha avuto il piacere di
conoscere persone stimolanti dalla
diversa intelligenza non riuscivo a
visualizzare i miei sogni
i sogni che in qualche modo avrebbero
orientato il mio futuro non so se
corrisponde al vostro modo di vedere
questa questo concetto io ci ho pensato
molto
io l'ho visualizzavo come qualcosa di
materiale come dire di quasi monolitico
e il mio timore era quello che avrei
passato la vita a cercare qualcosa con
quelle identità
avevo paura che avrei passato la vita
alla ricerca di una nuova coda di volpe
ho lasciato milano e sono scesa giù
utilizzo questa frase a molti di voi
nota perché la frase che tutti gli
emigranti della conoscenza meridionali
dicono ai propri colleghi amici quando
tornano a casa e così sono rientrata e
sono entrata nell'azienda della mia
famiglia sono entrata nel sogno di mio
padre
un sogno che lui vedeva a colori e io in
qualche modo vedevo in bianco e nero
mi ci è voluto un po ma poi ho capito
non era quello il mio sogno
avevo bisogno in qualche modo di creare
un percorso personale e ritrovare il
piacere di sognare un sogno tutto mio ed
attivare un processo non tanto di
ricerca quanto di ideazione
dovevo risalire su quella giostra e
divertirmi il più possibile nel
tentativo di raggiungere i miei nuovi
obiettivi e così feci al principio mi
sono trovata da sola
quanti di voi conoscono il nome di
questa giostra o quantomeno il nome che
noi qui al sud
diamo questa giostra penso tutti giusta
esatto la sapete bene come come funziona
se si è soli
se non c'è nessuno con te dietro di te
davanti a te non c'è nessun tipo di
chance di raggiungere l'obiettivo è non
c'è per nessuno né per te ne per gli
altri
e allora ho iniziato a lavorarci su
oggi e sono emozionata nel dirlo sono
amministratore delegato e fondatore di
due aziende tecnologiche una opera nel
settore degli apr meglio noti come i
droni aeromobili a pilotaggio remoto
l'altra offre una soluzione di mobilità
urbana intelligente per l'inclusione
sociale
entrambe le mie imprese ed è questo il
termine che più adoro preferibile al
termine start up che sembrano gioco per
bambini mi danno la chance enorme di
volare con i piedi per terra e di
sognare ad occhi aperti
cosa succede quando sogniamo durante il
sonno il cervello si attiva quasi nella
sua totalità tanto da chiedere un flusso
di sangue maggiore rispetto a quello che
viene richiesto durante durante la
veglia
l'unico punto del cervello che pare
bloccarsi e il suo centro logico insomma
durante il sogno si crea una condizione
favorevole al dispiegamento della
fantasia e del tono emozionale sapete
qual è il sogno più comune presso ogni
popolo e cultura del passato del
presente
avete visto il mio il titolo della mia
presentazione questo il sogno di volare
il volo è una tra le più belle
esperienze oniriche che l'individuo
possa compiere nel sogno durante il
operiamo una sorta di distacco dal
nostro corpo
saliamo in alto al di sopra di tutto e
di tutti
volare nel sogno ci fa sentire capaci e
potenti
riporto questa riflessione sul sogno un
po perché il fil rouge della del mio
intervento ma anche per altre due
ragioni entrambe egoistiche la prima
perché sognare di volare anche solo
pensare di sognare di volare mi
rasserena moltissimo ed è un meccanismo
per gestire l'emozione che questo palco
vi assicuro da la seconda ragione
risiede nel voler agganciare la vostra
attenzione perché il sogno di volare è
comune a tutti noi o per lo meno lo è
stato quando tutti noi eravamo bambini
le persone passano un terzo della
propria vita sognando qualche dato
ciò significa 70 primavere quasi
vent'anni di vita onirica facciamo
130.000 sogni nel corso di una vita dai
4 ai 7 ogni notte
pensate che alcuni sognano in bianco e
nero io non so com'è possibile
ma questo dicono le statistiche e tutti
veramente tutti hanno sognato almeno una
volta di volare il desiderio di
sollevare i piedi da terra sito si perde
nella notte dei tempi a noi sono
arrivati miti e leggende anche
dall'esito infausto
pensiamo ad icaro al quale il sole
sciolse la sera con la cera con cui si
era attaccato le ali al corpo oppure
simon mago che ai tempi dell'antica roma
volo davanti a nerone per poi
precipitare al suolo
c'è un uomo in particolare che non si
stanca mai di trovare una soluzione un
problema vedere la sua ombra attaccata
ai suoi piedi
quest'uomo fu leonardo che progettò
macchine volanti meravigliose che furono
la base per altri uomini che potevano
continuare a sognare sui quaderni di
leonardo si legge le ali verranno
verranno se non per merito mio per
merito di qualcun altro ma l'uomo volerà
e affianco a quella scritta c'era un bel
disegno
una macchina con un'asta di ferro a cui
erano fissate due ali che azionate da un
sistema di corde avrebbero in qualche
modo sottile sollevato l'uomo da terra
bene questa macchina per chi conosce i
droni e molto molto simile ai rotori
brushless che azionano il volo e
consentono agli apr ai droni di
sollevarsi di decollare dopo leonardo ci
fu francesco lana e poi i meravigliosi
fratelli mongolfiere a cui si deve il
primo volo finito con successo senza
incidenti loro volarono in mongolfiera
25 minuti a 1000 metri di altezza
sorvolando parigi
ed ecco che come aveva preannunciato
leonardo quasi quattro secoli prima le
ali arrivarono il primo vero aeroplano
fu opera ancora una volta di due
fratelli l'ho trovata una cosa
interessante due inventori statunitensi
fratelli wright che nel 1903 costruirono
un apparecchio con due ali e un motore a
benzina che si solleva da terra tra le
risa di molti per pochissimi secondi in
una spiaggia del north caroline
nacque così il primo aeroplano una
macchina più pesante dell'aria con le
ali capaci capace di portare uomini a
bordo
dopo i fratelli wright nel corso
dell'ultimo secolo l'uomo ha cambiato la
sua vita ha costruito satelliti sazioni
pack spaziali ha strutturato reti di
comunicazione intangibili e capillari
stime e dal riso la conquista del cielo
possibile per tutti veramente tutti ma
il sogno di volare non ha fine e anche
quando questo sogno pareva essere
realizzato
l'uomo non ha smesso di cimentarsi ha
trasformato il suo bisogno conquistare
il cielo non con il corpo ma con la
mente rendendo l'esperienza del volo
possibile per per scopi diversi nuovi
lontani dallo scopo del dl del viaggio
dello spostamento
un volo possibile anche per chi ha paura
di volare per chi ha la sindrome del
navigatore
nascono così i droni commerciali si
tratta di come vi dicevo aeromobili a
pilotaggio remoto una tecnologia senza
uomo porto queste reo mobili che
funzionano grazie a gps giroscopi e
accelerometri e batterie sempre più
capaci sono utili in settori
diversissimi
il primo il trasporto delle cose la
magia di trasportare le cose senza uomo
bordo
amazon zalando una seconda applicazione
che io trovo il grandissimo interesse
quella dell'agricoltura e l'agricoltura
di precisione
noi droni in questo ambito li
utilizziamo come collettori precisissimi
di dati e di informazioni che una volta
processati sono in grado di indirizzare
le decisioni dell'agricoltore del futuro
per risparmiare la risorsa idrica
efficientare l'utilizzo di pesticidi e
di fitofarmaci utile e ovviamente anche
nel settore della sicurezza azione di
intelligence protezione civile fire
fighting monitoraggio delle
infrastrutture ma prima di ogni cosa
i droni in questa mia fa ora sul sogno
di volare sono qui per raccontarci un
nuovo punto di vista
[Musica]
no
la visione dall'alto come avete visto
permette l'osservazione delle cose in
modo nuovo dandoci nuove consapevolezze
in questo caso la consapevolezza
immediata di così tanta bellezza la
visione dall'alto ci aiuta a cogliere
elementi altrimenti impossibili da
vedere guardare le cose dall'alto ci
aiuta ad evitare la miopia generata dall
osservazione troppo ravvicinata guardare
le cose dall'alto ci permette di creare
una visione al contempo personale ed
esatta di ciò che osserviamo perché sono
salito quassù indovina per sentirsi no
grazie per aver partecipato sono salito
sulla cattedra per ricordare a me stesso
che dobbiamo sempre guardare le cose da
angolazioni diverse e il mondo appare
diverso da quassù non vi ho convinti
venite a vedere voi stessi coraggio
è proprio quando credete di sapere
qualcosa che dovete guardarla da
un'altra prospettiva
anche se può sembrare sciocco o assurdo
ci dovete prova ecco quando leggete non
considerate soltanto l'autore
considerate quello che voi pensate
figlioli dovete combattere per trovare
la vostra voce più tardi cominciate a
farlo più grosso il rischio di non
trovarlo ha fatto però dice molti uomini
hanno vita di quieta disperazione non vi
rassegnate a questo
ribellatevi non affidatevi nella
pigrizia mentale guardatevi intorno è
così bravo per iscriversi posate
cambiare cercate nuove strade
robbie williams in questo magnifico film
che l'attimo fuggente ci dice usate
cambiare cercate nuove strade
il professor keating ci chiede di
sognare durante il sonno il nostro
cervello pesca quella tra pensieri
memorie immagini di disgrega per poi
riassemblarli in modo nuovo non
convenzionale e certamente trasformato
aiutandoci appunto trovare nuove strade
pensiamo che questo accade anche a dei
grandi della nostra storia mendeleev si
dice che abbia disegnato la tavola dei
65 elementi chimici conosciuti dopo il
sogno di una notte
lo stesso accade a bor con il sistema
atomico einstein trascorsi un'esistenza
a lavorare su un sogno che veda ragazzo
e paul mccartney si dice che abbia
composto yesterday nel sogno in un unico
sogno
io onestamente nutro qualche dubbio
sulla validità scientifica di questi
racconti non loro ma probabilmente chi
ce li ha riportati a maliziosamente
romanzato ma io lo capisco lo sto
facendo qui con voi anch'io sto
flirtando con il sogno su questo su
questo palco la parola sogno l'abbiamo
sentita in tutti gli interventi che
hanno preceduto questo è una una parola
inclusa in tutte le canzoni d'amore e
moltissime in moltissime campagne
politiche è una delle parole più cercate
sul web è più utilizzate
ma nella
parte dei casi significato che veste non
è quello onirico
quando parliamo di sogno noi parliamo di
sogno ad occhi aperti
quel processo che porta alla produzione
delle idee sognare nel senso di generare
pensieri creativi innovativi
torniamo al sogno di volare da cui siamo
partiti che cosa distingue l'uomo con
l'ato talare da samantha cristoforetti
cosa distingue l'avventuriero delle
piccole dolomiti lucane da wong frank
lui è il fondatore della dj a è la più
grande azienda produttrice di droni
commerciale che esiste al mondo in
questa mia visione delle cose e li
accomuna il sogno di volare
evidentemente li differenzia tante e
tanti altri elementi ma i primi l'uomo
con la tuta alare e l'avventuriero sono
in qualche modo mossi dalla curiosità
dall'istinto i secondi la cristoforetti
e franco wong dal dal desiderio il
desiderio come elemento che orienta le
scelte
il desiderio come segno lasciato dal
sogno energia che con che conduce
l'individuo resiliente verso l'obiettivo
invece una foto di vacchi perché viene
silenzio si parla tantissimo anche
troppo ho pensato potesse essere anche
un elemento banale ma in questa mia
visione del del mondo
l'uomo resiliente possiamo andare avanti
perché non è solo l'uomo capace di
persistere nel perseguire obiettivi
sfidanti con una motivazione che rimane
salda nel tempo ma anche il sognatore in
grado ancora una volta di sviluppare
strumenti di pensiero laterale e di
passa per leggere i dettagli e le pieghe
delle dinamiche senza che peraltro
questa finezza interpretativa generi la
miopia di cui parlavamo e
l'impossibilità di agire la mia ideas
worth spreading legata alla mia
esperienza
sta nel volare valere e volere
grazie